[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
être nous
un de nos proches
nous pourrions aussi être celle ou celui
qui va lui sauver la vie
qui n'a jamais rêvé de le faire
sincèrement sauver des vies être héros
nous ne sommes pas tous secouriste
médecin ou pompiers mais nous pouvons
tous sauver des vies avec un geste
simple le don du sang et il n'est pas
nécessaire de donner pour sauver il
suffit parfois d'en parler
chaque année dans le monde plus de 100
millions de poches sont prélevés pour
être transfusé aux personnes qui en ont
besoin
ces personnes ce sont des malades de
tous âges du bébé qui naît avec
l'incapacité de produire des globules
efficace jusqu'à la personne âgée dont
on va prolonger la vie de quelques
semaines quelques mois peut-être même
quelques années et puis il ya tout un
tas de maladies de pathologies qu'on va
pouvoir soulager grâce aux transfusions
il y a aussi les femmes dont
l'accouchement et hémorragiques avant
les transfusions c'est une sur deux qui
mouraient à la naissance de son enfant
et puis il ya les victimes d'accidents
d'agression
nous pouvons tous à un moment de notre
vie avoir besoin de sang
et pour en recevoir
il faut que des gens en est donnée y at
il ici ce soir des personnes qui ont
déjà donné leur sang
ok
y at il des personnes qui ne se sont
jamais présentés sur un lieu de collecte
alors soyez pas timides anormalement
vous êtes majoritaires
et a fait quoi du coup
le tu es allé sur un lieu de collecte et
a fait un malaise en voyant l'éguille
ça arrive et c'est pas grave d'ailleurs
il ya plein de raisons pour lesquelles
on peut ne pas pouvoir donner son sang
parce que pour donner il ne suffit pas
de vouloir il faut aussi pouvoir c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'éligibilité et selon
certaines études seuls 40% de la
population est éligible au don du sang
oui moins d'une personne sur deux ça
paraît peu
mais ce qui paraît encore moins c'est
que sur ces 40 % il n'ya qu'une personne
sur dix qui va franchir le pas et au
final c'est seulement 4 % de la
population qui donne
ça c'est vraiment peu
comment est-ce que ça se fait
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on donne ou pas
alors pour moi c'est facile mais déjà
parce que je travaille là bas ensuite
parce que je viens d'une grande famille
de donneurs chez nous tout le monde
donne mes parents mes frères et soeurs
et avant nous nos grandes parents déjà
donné leur sang le plus fort ou le plus
fou peut-être c'est mon grand père
maternel
imaginez un peu oui c'était à la ya
longtemps dans les années 60
en plein désert
en mission militaire
un camarade a besoin d'une transfusion
ils sont compatibles et qu'est ce qui va
se passer
bah oui il va lui donner son sang lui
sauver la vie en direct et puis quand je
dis en direct c'est pas une image une
aiguille dans un bras une aiguille dans
l'autre et c'est parti
impressionnant non
alors je vous rassure tout de suite
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça se
passe aujourd'hui les techniques ont
beaucoup évolué aujourd'hui
pour donner son sang on se présente sur
un lieu de collecte
on remplit un questionnaire
et puis on va rencontrer une personne
qui détermine si oui ou non on peut
donner vous vous rappelez 40% seulement
de la population est éligible ça c'est
mon travail je vais donc évaluer
différents critères
déjà il y à l'âge
avant 18 ans on est trop jeune
et après 70 ans
on est trop vieux
et puis il y à l'état de santé de la
personne qui donne il faut être
suffisamment en forme pour ça certaines
maladies cardiaques neurologiques
hématologiques
ne permettent pas le don du sang dans
ces cas là il vaut mieux prendre un
petit peu de repos parce qu'on veut
aussi protéger la personne qui donne et
puis bien sûr il ya la personne qui
reçoit on ne veut pas lui faire courir
de risques certains voyagent tatouage
changement de partenaire sexuel
entraîneront une contre-indication de
quatre mois mais si tous ces critères
sont respectés
vous trouverez la liste en ligne un je
vous la fais pas en entier c'est parti
pour le don
simple rapide le prélèvement dure
seulement dix minutes
pile le temps de regarder une conférence
tedx
après ça pour vous c'est bon vous avez
fait votre part vous pouvez passer en
zone de collation vous reposer manger un
morceau
eh bien vous hydrater
merci mais la poche elle ne s'arrête pas
là après avoir été prélevée elle va être
transporté au laboratoire pour être
technique et d'un côté votre sens va
être analysé de quel groupe sanguin et
vous combien de globules contenait votre
sang ce jour là
et surtout
y avait-il des microbes
si oui
votre poche va être écarté puis
détruites on ne veut pas faire courir de
risques à la personne qui reçoit ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle la qualification
biologique du don la poche pendant ce
temps va passer en préparation oui parce
que nous ce qu'on donne en dix minutes
c'est du centre total mais il n'est pas
transfusé tel quel il va être séparé en
ses différents composants pour être
distribués selon les besoins le sang
c'est des globules rouges des plaquettes
des globules blancs et du plasma pour
transporter tout ça
les globules rouges
il transporte l'oxygène dans l'organisme
c'est vital c'est eux que vous voyez
dans les poches rouge contre ans usa
l'hôpital
les plaquettes
elles servent à boucher les trous
lorsqu'on se blesse qu'on saigne elles
viennent arrêter l'hémorragie
et les globules blancs ce sont les
gardiens de l'organisme propre à chacun
ils sont uniques ils nous protègent mais
on ne peut pas les transfusés
le plasma c'est le liquide qui
transportent tout ça il fait le lien
entre les différents organes
bon c'est parce qu'il ya plus facile à
mi mai mais c'est très facile à
reconstituer après un don de sang
après un bain de sang si on est en bonne
santé on s'hydrate bien et on
reconstitue dans la journée le liquide
qui nous a été prélevée pour les
globules blancs et les plaquettes c'est
pareil en quelques jours on les refait
les globules rouges par contre c'est un
peu plus long dans notre corps leur
durée de vie elle est de 21 jours donc
en général il faut trois semaines pour
les reconstituer jusqu'à un mois c'est
pour ça qu'il ya un délai de deux mois
entre deux dons de sang pour que notre
corps puisse se reposer et refaire ses
réserves mais quand on les prélève ces
globules rouges on les met au frais dans
une solution de conservation ils peuvent
alors qu'à obtenir 42 jours
ça paraît beaucoup non
mais vous vous rappelez
100 millions de poches chaque année plus
de deux millions par semaine c'est tous
les jours qu'on a besoin de sang toute
l'année pas seulement quand on y pense
une fois de temps en temps pas seulement
quand il ya des appel urgent aux dons
parce que qu'est ce qui se passe si
jamais on manque de sens si jamais on
n'a pas assez de sang si jamais on n'a
pas des poches du groupe suffisant on va
se retrouver avec une personne qu'on
pourrait sauver et qui va mourir faute
d'avoir été transfusés si on n'a pas
assez de sang en stock on va se
retrouver à devoir sélectionner à qui on
va transfusé le peu de poche dont on
dispose on a besoin de vous tout le
temps les personnes qui sont éligibles
si chacun d'entre vous si chacun d'entre
nous donne son sang deux fois par an on
n'aura plus jamais besoin de lancer des
appels aux dons et pour toutes les
personnes qui ne peuvent pas ou ne
veulent pas redonné il ya aucun problème
pour ça vous pouvez aussi faire votre
part vous aussi vous pouvez aider vous
aussi vous pouvez contribuer à sauver
des vies comment
en en parlant en partageant des articles
en accompagnant des amis des collègues
ou même en rejoignant une association de
promotion du don du sang pour qu'on est
toujours en stock des poches préparer
qualifié sécurisé est prête à être
transfusé aux personnes qui en ont
besoin
ces personnes c'est peut-être des
inconnus mais ça peut aussi être des
proches
ou bien nous
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]